Speaker 1: let's keep chatting
with people because we really have
so many different people here who want to check
in. Let's go next to next to Zach from Toronto,
Canada. Zach, you're on the air.
Speaker 4: Hey, David,
Speaker 1: can you hear me? I can hear you,
you're discord is blinking, so please mute that.
Or maybe we can just come back to you later.
Speaker 3: OK, I have it on Do Not Disturb,
search, mute search shouldn't be any more good,
beautiful. I just wanted to say that I'm a really
big fan of the show. Thank you. And I wanted to
ask, do you like what do you see a line with?
Kind of like what the Republicans are saying
right now. Like I look at like Madison Cawthorn
saying like there will be bloodshed
and like Marjorie Taylor Green
influencing people to, like, shoot
vaccinated people. Do you see a line
with the Republican Party? Like do you see
Speaker 1: like the I mean,
do I see a line they won't cross?
Speaker 3: Yeah, yeah, that's what I
Speaker 1: do not really know, I mean, I
think I think the here's the thing, the line,
they won't there is no moral line that they won't
cross. The line they won't cross is over into what
they think will be bad for them electorally or
will be bad for their fundraising. But morally,
I see no line that they're unwilling to cross. No.
Speaker 3: OK. And do you have any feelings of how
that will look in, say, 2020 or 2024 if,
like Marjorie Taylor Green and Warren Bubar
continue getting the support they have right now?
Speaker 1: So I'm going to let you go because of
the discord. Won't stop blogging. I'll answer
the question off air. The twenty twenty two is
going to look like now. So my my belief is these
Trumpy and radicals are going to go into twenty
the way that they they've been this year. If it
wins them reelection in twenty two, they will be
emboldened and Trump will almost certainly run
in twenty four. If they get defeated with this
nonsense in twenty two they will have to rethink
it. And so I think the question is, once we the
issue is once we know how 22 goes for them, then
we'll be able to say if and how they'll modify
their approach. But morally, I'm not aware of any
line that these people are unwilling to cross.